and we continue our month-long series in
your neighborhood and this morning we're
taking you inside chinatown in spring
mountain
john langler live there at shanghai
plaza with a look at what's happening hi
john good morning
good morning to you alex and a good
morning to you at home as well we all
kind of know what chinatown is the area
right along spring mountain corridor
this is
shanghai plaza which opened in january
of 2020
basically the newest major development
that happened in this area
and it's an example of why it is so
popular because
you know we do call it chinatown but it
is so much more diverse than that there
are many different cultures
many different parts of asia that are
represented here and serving up some
very tasty food
when borman yang first opened taiwan
deli she also used to sleep here
such as her dedication her hard work
nearly 20 years later
she says it's paid off people want to
have a good food
where they go chinatown taiwan deli is
one of more than a hundred restaurants
in chinatown
but of course the neighborhood is not
just chinese food it's just one of many
ways the area is so unique
korea people come japanese people come
and
vietnamese people come so there's a
whole street
you want to have all kind of crew it's
just a whole street
what i notice about our uh quote
chinatown is it's very
ethnically diverse rana khan zilla
pasawan owns archie's tide just off the
main chinatown core
it might not be as big as the ones in la
and all that but
you know i think for the small city that
we are it's pretty impressive
little chinatown but chinatown's
enthusiasm was dented by the pandemic
yang says she lost up to 80 percent of
her business when asian travel
evaporated many spring mountain
restaurants depend on those visitors
from the strip
but here community organizations helped
businesses and families stay afloat
now the same optimism seen across the
valley is throughout chinatown
considering everything that's gone on
the last year and i can't complain the
challenge is finding enough workers to
meet the demand for service
unemployment coming in being a huge
competition for
our staff you know people had to make
decisions
like dishwashers are gonna they're
looking at a check they've never seen in
their life
where they want to show up to work and
make happen
yang has hired back many of her staff
she says she's even helped keep them in
their homes
it's a long way from when her own home
was her own business
why do you still do it i love it
she certainly does borman is a very
interesting character over at taiwan
deli her brother is a well-known singer
back in taiwan and she sort of
manages to entertain her own uh
customers when they're over there
having their breakfast and lunch as well
so uh this is of course chinatown we
understand this is sort of
the original chinatown of las vegas but
there is about seven percent of the
population
is aapi asian american pacific islander
in the valley
the southwest valley especially and
parts of henderson are also seeing
a big increase in asian business and
investment from california especially
and from overseas
coming here setting up roots in las
vegas because there is so much demand
alex will send it back to you in the
studio there is a lot of demand and
langler
it is 6 39 20 more minutes
hang tight my friend still waiting we're
waiting seven o'clock is just a few
minutes away
yeah you did such a great job profiling
that neighborhood it's really cool to
see it thank you so much john we'll see
a bit later